[Музика]
знову привіт, це нерівномірно і
зібрано з вами під час онлайн-
занять англійською мовою, і я дуже радий
знову вітати мого дорогого колегу та
друга Mr.  Павло о, привіт, Павло,
так радий повернутися знову Оксана, це
чудово, чи сподобався вам наш останній урок
так, мені завжди сподобалося
викладати 5 клас 5 класу дуже весело так, я згоден
з тобою, тому що ти можеш проводити багато
веселих заходів, включаючи ігри та вірші
і пісні, які з ними, так, добре,
і сьогодні ми збираємося розпочати нашу нову
тему, яка насправді присвячена нашому
шкільному житті, я сподіваюся, що у вас залишилися тільки
хороші спогади з вашої школи,
можливо, так голосно, що я не можу згадати міс
Золя  ви, мабуть, жартуєте, ви завжди
жартуєте, містер.  Пол добре, хлопці, тому ми
дізнаємося пізніше про Mr.
Досвід Пола в школі, а також
досвід ваших вчителів у школі, але тепер
давайте почнемо, і ми отримали дуже
таємниче повідомлення, давайте подивимося на
це добре, містере.  Пол подивіться, чи
можете ви впізнати будь-який із цих символів,
ні, це трохи схоже на якийсь
секретний код так,
насправді я знайшов його сьогодні на своєму столі, але
я сподіваюся, що ви допоможете нам розшифрувати
повідомлення, яке було надіслано для нас, тому в
у верхньому лівому куті ви бачите символи
та букву, яку
вони означають, а в нижньому правому
куті ви бачите повідомлення
так ви
хочете знати, що там написано, так,
тому що мені надто важко
зламати цей код, тому насправді
ви можете побачити англійський алфавіт, а
поруч з ним є спеціальні символи,
які відповідають кожній літері правильно, і
вам потрібно його зламати  один за одним, якщо ви
почнете робити це, то цей знак річки
означає букву G, потім R, потім подвійне e,
і, можливо, ви вгадуєте слово
зелені привітання
так, це вітання, чи у вас є ті
самі хлопці, тож це слово привітання
закодовано в нашому повідомленні  але  є
інше слово привітання,
можливо, ми дізнаємося, від кого це
повідомлення, так що привітання, а зворотна сторона
означає суп, а потім стрілка вниз
M, тоді коло є розумним.
crack it, хлопці, я сподіваюся, що так, тому
є ще одна підказка, хлопці, ви можете використовувати
цей секретний код для доставки повідомлень
своїм друзям і бути впевненим, що ніхто не
дізнається, що відбувається, добре,
тому це більше Mr.  Пол, як нам
вдалося зламати цей код, ми, очевидно,
ви знаєте, ми
зіставили букву з
буквами клавіш, щоб ми вирішили
холод, ми зламали холод, ми
точно розшифрували повідомлення, тому, хлопці, ми використовуємо в будь-яких
шкільних предметах  спеціальні символи коди,
які позначають різну інформацію mr.
Папа, ми так, у нас все добре, зараз
давайте подивимося на інший екран, щоб було
три символи, давайте спробуємо вгадати,
які предмети вони представляють, тож
перші літери та цифри та деякі
дивні символи, що вони означають, ви
знаєте це я  пам'ятаю, я пам'ятаю це
зі школи, місіс.  честь, тому що довгота,
давайте просто перевіримо, що я правильний, довгота
– це лінії на земній кулі, які йдуть вниз по
широті – це лінії на земній кулі, які
йдуть поперек, і я пам’ятаю, я сподіваюся, що я
пам’ятаю, що Сполучене Королівство знаходиться на 52
градуси широти, тому це положення
місце на земній кулі, тому це має бути
пов'язано з земною кулі, це має бути
щось пов'язане з географією,
точніше, можливо, ви можете здогадатися, яке
положення міста це говорить нам тут, якщо
Лондону Італії 52, що може бути 50, я
думаю, що це повинно  будь Київ
так, це правда, це ключ
положення на земній кулі, добре, якщо говорити
про наступний знак червоне коло, що
всередині цього червоного кола є чотири
символи, так це досить легко, це
дуже відомо в усьому світі,
це множення  ділення
додавання віднімання, тож це
математика так, правильно, це було дуже
легко для вас я б сказав легко peasy
lemon squeezy так, і остання там
ми бачимо
кілька літер, за якими вони кажуть, що e дорівнює MC
вдвічі, що це могло б це  на
щастя, це дуже відомий,
тому що, на жаль, я теж погано ставився до
фізики,
тому, якби зв'язатися з фізикою було щось важче,
я б із труднощами
відповісти на це питання, але це цілком може
бути найвідомішим фізичним кодом або
символом у цілому  світу, так це
пов'язано з фізикою так, але
ви пам'ятаєте, що в Україні і я не
впевнений, але, можливо, у Великобританії також
діти в п'ятому класі не вивчають
фізику, так що може бути предметом для
наших дітей, так  У Великобританії також після 5-го року
вони, як правило, спеціалізуються на фізиці,
біології або хімії, і всі ці три
предмети складають науку так,
це наука, добре, тому ми
підготували коди, і тепер ми
готові приступити до іншого завдання, добре зараз  у нас
є словник малюнків, який є
досить популярним для нас і допомагає нам
запам'ятати різні слова, а саме
які слова ми тут маємо,
ці предмети ми вивчаємо в школі так,
абсолютно правильно, так що робити  ти думаєш,
це буде картинка для історії
історії, можливо, кінь так, кінь,
тому що це ніч, можливо, нічний
бій, а зараз ми не використовуємо коней у
боях так точно, а потім наступний
український о, це має бути український
прапор  так, абсолютна
наука, це картина
з атомами, так і трубками, якісь
матеріали для тестування, тоді PE RPE фізкультура,
це була б гімнастика,
силуети людей, які правильно займаються
гімнастикою,
і я знаю, що пан.  поло, він
спеціалізується на гонорарах, я правий так, ти права,
Жанна, так, так що якщо ти хочеш знати,
яка вправа є найкращою, щоб підтримувати форму, ти
знаєш, до кого звертатися правильно, добре,
тоді мистецька музика може бути, я знаю цю,
хоча я"  Мені страшно, що будь-що з
музичним інструментом – це те, що
має ноту, і пензлик, так,
географія – це найпростіше, тому що
мова йде про земну кулю прямо
внизу, тоді англійська має бути алфавітом,
можливо, алфавітом, драма буде драма
дві маски, як у
акторів, так, і, до речі, у мене є
запитання, чи є у вас драма як
обов'язковий предмет, хлопці, значить
важливо зробити, що це обов'язково у вашому
розкладі ні у Великобританії це необов'язкове це
необов'язкове  так само, як в Україні право
і математика це обов'язкове
це обов'язкове і маса буде
символом, який ми бачили перед червоним колом
з поділеним плюсом і мінусом,
а також комп'ютерні дослідження, які також
можуть бути ІКТ, можливо, це ac
зображення комп'ютера, це єдине, що залишилося,
так, у нас немає іншого вибору, крім цього
, так, ми сподіваємося, що цей
словник зображень допоможе вам
краще запам'ятати назви предметів, і тепер ми рухаємося далі,
добре, хлопці, і тепер ми переглянули  і ми
навмисне запам'ятали назви предметів, тому що у мене є дуже
важливе завдання для вас і для пана.  polo
ви знаєте, що я вчитель і я
вже почав готувати свій розклад
на наступний навчальний рік, але,
на жаль, мій асистент не
заповнив мій розклад і тут мені потрібна ваша
допомога разом з паном.
дотримуйтесь, тому зараз вам потрібен аркуш
паперу та ручка, у вас буде близько 30
секунд, щоб намалювати таблицю, схожу
на ту, яку ви зараз бачите на своїх екранах,
добре, хлопці, тому я сподіваюся, що ви
готові, і зараз ми  починають
відчувати свій розклад на наступний
рік, щоб я міг почати готувати
матеріали та шукати книги
добре, Mr.  Пол, я готовий слухати тебе
добре, Оксана, у тебе історія у
вівторок і в четвер історія
о дев'ятій годині вівторка, добре, тому
я напишу історію тут, але як щодо
четверга я отримав перший урок англійської мови,
тому мені потрібно  поставити знак питання, тому
що я не впевнений, це історія чи ні, у
вас є українська до обіду у
вівторок, четвер і п'ятницю і після
обіду в середу.
Середа в середу після
обіду добре, так це українська добре,
дуже дякую, що буде далі добре, у
вас є комп'ютерні заняття у вівторок
і п'ятницю вранці Комп'ютерні заняття
в п'ятницю о дев'ятій годині, так що
комп'ютерні дослідження
йдуть між історією та  українська у
вівторок і п'ятницю дев'ята година добре
я закінчив у
вас є чотири уроки природничих наук на тиждень
о боже мій на тиждень один у понеділок
вранці, один у середу
вдень, інші два о першій
і  О 2 годині четверга,
добре, повторіть, будь ласка, добре, так що у
вас є чотири уроки або природознавство. Перший
урок у понеділок вранці мм-хм
так, він тут, так що другий урок
у середу вдень, добре, і два
інших уроки природознавства  1:00 і
2:00 у четвер, я бачу, мені
цікаво, що ми будемо робити під час
цих уроків природознавства, так багато з них у
понеділок вдень, у вас є дві години
фізкультури в понеділок вдень дві години о, я
я буду дуже втомлений добре, у вас є дві
години мистецтва у вівторок вдень добре,
дякую, що буде далі, у
вас музика після англійської в
середу і до драми в п'ятницю
музика після англійської в середу, тому я
думаю, що це буде тут і після
перед драмою в п'ятницю це чудово, добре,
і нарешті у вас є географія в
середу та вранці в понеділок, а в
понеділок географія після науки, а
в середу 9 годин добре, а
тут
правильно, і я думаю, що щось не
вистачає, тому я вважаю  ess мій
помічник щойно пропустив заняття, що
нам робити, давайте подивимося, чого не вистачає, так що
науки, я думаю, я впевнений, що чотири заняття
на тиждень більше, ніж наша модель уроків мистецтва
2p2 музика драма математика High City
[Музика]
англійська один-два класи  Англійська мова
і лише два класи математики, тому я думаю, що
ми не будемо мати двох класів англійської мови
в один день,
ні, так, ймовірно, це має бути математика,
тож ви можете вгадати, кому я
буду скаржитися на свій розклад, ваші
системи  Абсолютно це смішно,
так математика тут, так що англійська залишається
тут, а тут
я думаю, математика та англійська, тож тепер
уроки англійської на тиждень так, ви знаєте, я
люблю це, це мій улюблений клас,
звичайно, я був би щасливий, якби я мав
усі уроки англійської мови  цілий тиждень
добре, хлопці, подивіться на
дошку та перевірте, чи є у вас такі самі
відповіді, як і ми
, і тепер, коли ми завершили наш
розклад, ми поглянемо
на вправи на повторення граматики та
пояснення, давайте  подивіться,
які дії ми використовуємо теперішню просту
форму, щоб наш розклад можна було ідеально
описати теперішнім простим часом,
то які дії ми робимо лише для
звичайних рутинних дій щоденного
розкладу так,
і ми просто згадаємо, як  щоб утворити цей
час,
то чи пам’ятаєте ви, що у нас є спеціальні
правила для дієслова to be в теперішньому і
минулому, тому в теперішньому він змінюється
залежно від того, про кого ми говоримо, тому
він має форми M є R, якщо ми говоримо
про I про  я завжди використовуємо em, якщо
ми говоримо про він, вона і це, ми будемо використовувати
це, а коли ми говоримо про ми, ви і
вони будуть використовувати, також після дієслова to
be ми не збираємося використовувати будь-яке
слово дії буде використовувати іменник або  прикметник,
наприклад, я вчитель, а мій
партнер чудова людина, тоді, коли ми хочемо
використовувати негатив, додамо частинку not
до M є R, і це зробить я НЕ,
він не є, і ми не є, і коли ми
поставте запитання, які
ми поставили M є або на перше місце тоді
йде хто це робить, а потім в
решті речення ситуація
дещо інша зі словами дії
з дієсловами, тому, коли ми говоримо про
дію,
коли ми розповідаємо про щось, що ми
регулярно робимо щодня, ми повторюємо це з I
we you, і вони будуть  використовуйте лише основну
форму дієслова I drink you speak we
follow they listen, але коли ми говоримо
про його, вона, і якщо нам потрібно додати
двигун, коли вона говорить, він слухає, це дощ,
а решта речення в
негативах ми маємо  helper don't for I
will use day and does not for he she it
наступне за дієсловом без будь-яких
змін, а решта речення
в питаннях we will have do and us
на першому місці після йде who does
it and then  тип дії, який виконується,
і тепер я пропоную нам потренуватися в цій
часовій формі дуже незвичайним способом.
Ви коли-небудь чули про сенсаційні вірші
Я читав деякі вірші, які, можливо, були
сенсаційними, але я ніколи не чув про
сенсаційні вірші  добре, так давайте
ха  подивившись на них так сенсаційний вірш
про школу, я вже сказав,
щоб створити власний вірш про
школу, в якій ми навчаємося, тому в першому рядку
вам потрібно вказати колір теми,
щоб колір школи чи загальний
ідея, яку ви хотіли б висловити про
свою школу в рядку номер два, ви
повинні порівняти свою школу зі смаком, який
вона має в рядку номер три, зі
звуками, які ви можете почути рядок номер
чотири запахи, які ви відчуваєте, рядок номер п'ять, як
це виглядає і  рядок номер шість, як ви
відчуваєте себе відвідувати вашу дивовижну школу
, до речі, я вже
підготував для вас чернетку
, приклад добре, але, як ви бачите, у них
відсутні слова, ви допоможете мені з ними,
будь ласка, добре, давайте спробуємо зробити це разом,
щоб наші  сенсаційний вірш про школу
наша школа яскраві кольори всюди, яке
слово ми можемо додати тут, що ви думаєте
добре це дієслово to have, але оскільки
ми використовуємо наш, ми повинні використовувати як так, ми
перевіримо пізніше, щоб наша шкільна місіс
позує  має бриг  ht кольори скрізь і
як смачний курячий суп, що ми
тут опишемо, так що це курячий суп,
який був би таким, тому це
має бути на смак добре, тоді наступного
разу їжте, як сотні бджіл зебів, так
що це може бути, бджоли відомі  за
те, що ви трудоголіки, які багато працюють
без перерви щодня, працюють, працюють,
працюють, так що це, мабуть, працює, як
100 зайнятих бджіл, це хороший вибір, добре,
але як мед і лимонад, о, це
складно, так, я знаю, так, я відмовляюся
від Оксани.  не знаю цього добре,
давайте перейдемо далі, тоді, можливо, наші студенти
знають відповідь, ми перевіримо це пізніше, з'їмо
як казковий пиріг знову я не знаю
цього Олександре, можливо, наші студенти
можуть допомогти, можливо, добре, тож які ваші
припущення та  останнє, і ми почуваємось
найкращими способами добре, цей, я думаю,
робить нас добре, ви хочете перевірити, чи
ви були правильні чи ні, і з'ясуйте
ті, які я не знав, добре, добре, давайте
зробимо це,
так що ось
наша школа  всюди має яскраві кольори
d на смак схожий на смачний курячий суп, це
звучить як сотня зайнятих бджіл, але
пахне медовим лимонадом,
це виглядає як пиріг із хвостом феї, і змушує
нас почувати себе якнайкраще.
їж пиріг добре, я розумію,
але мені подобається твоя ідея про це працює, як
сотні зайнятих бджіл, правильно, це ще один
хороший варіант, тож чи можете ви вгадати, яке ваше
домашнє завдання, чому б вам не спробувати створити
такий сенсаційний вірш про свою
школу, щоб сьогодні разом з вами не створити такий сенсаційний вірш про свою школу  під час
нашого уроку англійської мови були Оксана
Іваненко та Mr.  Пол Лоу,
дуже дякую за
увагу і приєднавшись до нас, ми
побачимося наступного разу,
[музика]